the British government will ban Huawei
from having any role in providing
technology for its 5g networks from 2027
on with the company barred from
providing any new equipment from the end
of this year the UK previously gave the
Chinese company the green lights to
operate but following strong pressure
from the Trump administration to ban
Huawei completely the government has
made a dramatic u-turn citing serious
security concerns here's what the UK's
digital secretary Oliver Dowden had to
say the government agrees with the
National cybersecurity sensor advice the
best way to secure our networks is for
operators to stop using new affected
hawawa to equipment to build the UK's
future 5g networks so to be clear from
the end of this year telecoms operators
must not buy any 5g equipment from her
Huawei and once the telecom security
bill is passed
it will be illegal for them to do so
joining me now is Emily Taylor
an Associate Fellow at Chatham houses
international security program Emily
how significant is the decision to block
Huawei from the UK's 5g network it's
very significant not just at a technical
level and for the businesses of the
mobile operators it's also significant
geopolitically both for the impact on
the UK's relationship with China and
with the US and of course opening up
distance between the UK and the rest of
the European Union on this issue
why has the UK taken this decision now
and is it justified there are a number
of reasons why the UK has taken this
decision if you recall the UK announced
its position on Huawei back in January
and sought to sort of carve a middle way
if you like that would acknowledge the
security concerns voiced by the US and
other international allies but also kept
really business as usual for the mobile
operators the limit of 35 percent set
back in January very much reflected the
status quo
what we're seeing now is a ramping up of
tension there is a fairly respectable
technological excuse if you like for
changing position and that is the
unknown impact of US sanctions affecting
semiconductor chips supply but there are
lots and lots of other more political
reasons both internationally and
domestically where a fair number of the
of the governing parties representatives
are very opposed to having Huawei you
just mentioned international
repercussions do you expect this
decision from the UK to resonate
resonate outside of the UK very much so
because part of the drivers for
reopening the decision are about
international tensions China has already
had very harsh words for the UK in
response to Hongkong and there are also
tensions surrounding the Chinese
attitude towards the weaker Muslims I
think also the pandemic has played a
part and certainly affected public
opinion in the United Kingdom a recent
opinion poll done by the Financial Times
suggests that 83% of British people
don't trust China at the moment but this
is clearly an effort to move closer in
line with other five eyes partnerships
five eyes being the Intelligence Sharing
cooperation between the US Australia and
others but it will also cause problems
with China at a point where the UK is
exiting the European Union see making
those ties weaker with European partners
and the European European other member
states have been doing their own thing
with Huawei a despite called a you know
forest for an overall policy in overall
coordinated response in fact every
country I've been working out 5g in
their own way in countries has been to
use Huawei in some way
Emily Taylor of Chatham House thank you
very much thank you the German cabinet
is set to decide whether to make it
easier for intelligence agencies to
install spyware on computers and phones
to monitor encrypted communication
messaging services such as whatsapp
telegram and signal use end-to-end
encryption making hard to monitor under
the new proposed law techno technology
companies could be obliged to send
spyware to a user's device hidden as an
app or software update which could
access a user's microphone camera and
texts well the spyware proposal has cost
technology companies and civil society
organizations worried journalists groups
say it could be used to monitor on
reporters for example conducting
sensitive investigation
well our reporter Joel duro has been
following this for us Joe why do German
intelligence agency want these new
powers well today many of us use apps
for our communication we've moved away
from texts and emails and we use apps
such as whatsapp which has two billion
users worldwide and facebook Messenger
which is the second biggest now both of
these have end-to-end encryption which
means that it's very hard for those
messages to be monitored either by
hackers or government agencies now
that's made them popular with protest
organizers around the world as well as
journalists communicating with their
sources now security services might say
that they can also be used by criminals
and terrorists to send messages into
each other now today if a German
security agency wants to monitor a
device they have to get physical access
to it to install spyware on it or they
could trick the user into downloading a
piece of malicious code that would then
enable that to happen
but however under this new proposal the
German spy agencies wants to make that
easier they want to be able to install
spyware to track encrypted communication
without the user having to do anything
at all how would this work in practice
then sure well under this proposal which
is being discussed here in Germany as
the state trojan spyware proposal
technology companies would be obliged to
install monitoring technology in their
very data centers
then spy agencies could use that to send
a packet of malicious code to a user's
device and this could be very easily
done by hiding inside an app update or a
software update or even via an unsecure
website then the device could be
monitored including its camera its
microphone and keypad entries and this
would get around end-to-end encryption
because essentially they could monitor a
device from a user's perspective now
these kind of tools are already being
used in other countries but not here in
Germany which has a very high valuation
on privacy of course here and in fact
many Internet service providers here in
Germany are valued by companies and
users precisely because they operate
under such strict privacy rules but now
if this new law passes those same
companies could be conscripted to become
part of intelligence operations it
sounds like a very nifty solution - -
for intelligence agencies of course why
is everybody so worried well we've heard
from both business and civil society
groups who that are against this for
example the German Technology
Association bit calm it doesn't want its
members to have to be recruited into
these kind of operations and to
essentially act as middlemen for the spy
agencies we've also heard that
journalists groups are very worried
about this reported Without Borders says
the Interior Ministry has given no
explanation as to how state hacking of
journalists would be prohibited under
these new laws now we did ask the German
interior ministry for an explanation as
to why these new laws are necessary we
haven't heard back from them as of yet
now the German Cabinet is due tomorrow
to decide on this proposal it will then
have to go to the Parliament to be
approved but it could all end up in
Germany's Constitutional Court which has
in the past already ruled that Germans
have a right to be able to trust the
integrity and privacy of their devices
Joel Darwin thank you very much for this
update
you